[Musique]
bon le sol a tout de suite patron je ne
sois pas si pressée nounours et jamie
mac en jeu qu'ils vont être contents
popopopops gros bobos soir les enfants
vous aussi vous allez être contents car
nounours vous a réservé une surprise
au soir les petits
gars là a porté la super leicester de
filippi oui je vais vous la raconter
alors je me pose
où en étions-nous
[Musique]
l'année matin le lendemain matin
philippines se réveilla de très bonnes
mains elle prit son tambour et
moi aussi je vais jouer du tambour le
matin en me réveillant au oui ça frappe
ici la tap m les parents de philippine
ravi d'être réveillé citons demandeurs à
leur petite fille ronde est gentil ce
qu'elle désirait de si bonne heure
répondit philippines sa maman avait déjà
chauffée du lin du chocolat est posé sur
la table un paul des assiettes du sucre
du miel du fromage un appétit de la
confiture de prunes de la confiture de
pages de la confiture d'orange d'abricot
de la confiture de confiture mur elle
avait déposé un pot de confiture de
phrase
lorsque
piti piti piti
le lapin blanc entre a et mangera toute
la confiture de fraises
à tend la main à temps et philippine qui
avait très envie de jouer avec lui
essayé de l'attraper mais le lapin blanc
se sauva bien vite et philippine se mit
à pleurer
pour se consoler de ne pas avoir joué
avec le lapin blanc
philippines fit un excellent petit
déjeuner puis
repris son tambour
[Musique]
sketch bien
écouter la suite il fait beau allons
nous promener dans les proies propos ça
qui m'a poussé
je ne me rappelle plus je l'y aide
apportée lassus c'est malin
je vous le promets je vous la porterez
la prochaine fois je vous laisse le lit
oui vous êtes content
ça nous fait d'amis allons les enfants
où
annie neige notamment les nuits les plus
la jette à la ligne homme
fait deux tours
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle était très jolie ton histoire
nounours niko lol patronales l'ont
beaucoup plus on n'y va pas trop en
route la nuit les enfants fait de pur
[Musique]
bonsoir petit ami aux
eaux selon demain de feurs qu'elle s'y
oppose pas trop et oui nounours mais je
pense que nicolas et pimprenelle ont
quand même envie de voir mais moi aussi
j'ai envie de voir j'y vais de ce pas
bon le cheval
au pas pour
[Musique]
soi
c'est bien j -c soir
cornichons et partie oui dice est par
ailleurs venu chercher mais l'a promis
qu'il reviendra pas au mieux il
[Musique]
grimace
catcheur 9e ce qu'il dessine bien
je reconnais l'écriture d'emilia
ma chère tu sors qu'est ce qu'un magnat
cheikh sarr et les cris joyeux nos
caisses et gentil joyeux noël nous aussi
on fait avec les runes lettre tu veux
selon du jeu attrayant
et moi lotois qui nous ont fait les
dessins mes chiens
non chers amis merci pour votre belle
c'est le bonhomme de neige est très
réussi le bonhomme 2
vois je vous déçu naviaux et moi le
portrait de notre ami tony chan le
portrait si votre maman emilia vous le
permet nous ferons n'a de nouveau je
vois qu on s'amusera conso but mais à
bientôt gros baiser nicolas la traînait
là bon joueur
bon baisers nos meilleures salutations
ronchères et dévouée a mis pape rhône
elle et nicolas c'est plus élégant tu as
raison ça fait sérieux très bien je leur
envoie cette lettre par exprès ceux qui
vont être heureux d'avoir de vos
nouvelles
n'oubliez pas gelé juin bonne nuit les
enfants allaient vue de vous coucher on
y va tout seul
[Musique]
bonne nuit ch chronos au menu clair un
état prenait dors bien
[Musique]
où
pas trop vous vous arrêterez au dessus
du bureau de poste le plus proche j'ai
une lettre urgente a expédié d'accord
nounours en route la nuit les enfants
faute de
[Musique]
bourdieu
pas trop nous sommes arrivés
faisait pas trop nous sommes arrivés au
excuse-moi nounours je jouais du pipeau
je m'étais même pas rendu compte que
nous étions arrivés du pipeau du pipeau
vous étiez dans la lune oui mais moi je
suis pressé d'aller voir mes amis ne te
fâche pas nos forums
mon seul vote
propos pop ont beau
coucou c'est l'humour
[Musique]
j'ai dû me tromper de maisons excusé
excusez moi petit grandeur pardon madame
je suis trompé de maison ah oui je
cherche mademoiselle nicolas et monsieur
pas preneur non monsieur oh pardon
petite grand-mère ou
madame rôle là je m'en vais tout de
suite
[Musique]
monsieur mouche
ou non excusez-moi mais je n'aime pas
prendre l'ascenseur tiens tiens fermé
l'after
sur l'auvent
oui petit gros meurent
[Musique]
les curieux cette grand mère
parce que je parle à feneu a
alors se vend
quoi encore
[Musique]
elle a une drôle de façon de relier
cette grand mère et cette fenêtre qui
est encore fait remuer tout renfort aux
savants
et le voilà le vent je le tiens
[Musique]
t'as bien attrapé ça ou alors
[Rires]
[Musique]
prenait lé que j'ai une petite coquine
et toi nicolas un petit ça sonne ballon
en dormez-vous
[Musique]
au poteau le cocan
didon la prochaine fois c'est moi qui me
déguise rahan grand père
howie vannes unique à la tombe bien
petite grand mère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
or salon soir lors et qu'y a t'il
nounours ils deviennent de plus en plus
garnements patron il m'a encore fait une
farce et s'il ne t'en faisait plus north
je m'ennuie erreurs et bien tu vois tu
adores ça se re poteau bonne nuit les
petits vous aussi vous pouvez faire des
farces à nounours il sera ravi le mot
fuck propres
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous honneur
ouvert aujourd'hui
nous étions bien loin nous incombe
soit de rentrer deux pays
à temps
avec vous bien joué avez-vous bien
chanté avec lui j'étais gentil c'est ça
je crois que quelques enfants ont été
plutôt méchant patron de gestion jean
foillard
puisque l'eau entrant qui nous parle
dont 10 filles
megan fond
ce seront des j'habite petit antoine
tu es trop gentil
essaye d'en nous verrons oui mais à
condition qu'ils étaient
conduite de parfaits
patron vous serez surpris moi je vous le
garantis alors nous nous allons aussi
inquiétés
bonsoir le
enfin on est content aujourd'hui pour
bien longtemps
en bas
rené où tous les soirs
dire aux noceurs
bizarre
bonne nuit fais dix abris
[Musique]
qu'elle a
beau lui je faisais
mes petits enfants chéris
[Musique]
non non ne vous levez pas je suis trop
content que vous suiviez mes conseils et
que vous vous coucher tôt même quand je
ne suis pas là c'est très bien c'est
pour te faire plaisir maintenant parce
qu'on pense à moi je pense tout le temps
à vous chica tu ne vas aborder quelque
chose
je pense à vous mais je ne vous ai rien
apporté
allons
la g prend là le
monde or mais vite le tas je reviendrai
demain
bonne nuit
quelle curieuse association tout ne
t'inquiète pas je lui parlerai demain
entre à ce drôle de nounours t'as raison
nicolas il faut pas te laisser faire
bonne nuit ma petite pimprenelle leur
bien nicolas
[Musique]
patron il était déjà couché le shirk qui
ce que je suis content il m'écoute vous
savez il me coût d'un vieux nounours en
route hulu ou loup qu'est ce que tu dis
jeudi en août on langage bourse et bien
roudourou d'où nous donne ni les enfants
à deux coureurs
[Musique]
pour voir les enfants ont faim
il ya de l'orage douleur ce soir oui on
dirait nounours alors je reviendrai vite
patron ou le cheval europe hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop
et puis tu lui diras aussi ne t'inquiète
pas un petit peu prenait bonsoir les
enfants ça vous fait drôle de petite
tête ce soir
mais je n'avais pas les oui on va parler
tous les deux nous nous bien sûr nicolas
on va se parler entre avec moi je te
suis nicolas allons dans la cuisine bien
moi je voulais à trappes
[Musique]
on y collant mon petit non non non c'est
pas gentil tu ne penses pas nous tu nous
oublie tu pars en voyage et puis tu nous
rapporte rien
pauvres petits enfants et béthune nous
écrit pas aux eaux
et je suis un méchant nous nous sommes
passés gentil avec des amis au long tu
ne peux plus
toujours
[Musique]
nous a rien apporté je ne voulais pas
donner hier soir car vous étiez coucher
mais je ne vous ai pas oublié tenue
pour nicolas est longue pour pas preneur
c'est quand même gentil non robert
petit garnement
la prison au lit
[Musique]
mais où sont-ils
en dormez-vous vite vous n'avez pas été
gentil avec moi c'est fini on ne fera
plus jamais de reproche qui tienne
c'est pour toi une sucette
merci le zoo on
la jette à niort
fait de boer
la nuit de noces
[Musique]
oh
alors nounours le mot trop du une
sucette je le vois ce qu'il me patron
est ce qu aux jo les rares en route gros
sentimentale bonne nuit des enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents le peu
de boue retouches
[Musique]
par des enfants ou blanc et c'est une
ourse je me faisais pas trop je veux me
luc rabat ce soir je veux être ton
l'ours tu as raison mais tu as plutôt
l'air d'un humour désordonnée ceinture
jaune je vends mon le seul homme hop hop
hop hop hop hop
bonsoir alors on s'amuse j'ai envie de
rire ce soit
grave à
la mise à l'heure tu fais comme le roi
dagobert
assieds toi là
et voilà une belle couronne
je n'ai pas de culot ça fait rien tu
fais comme si ton avis
le bon roi dagobert
a mis sa culotte à l'envers
legrand cède élevé ni honorons votre
majesté et mac hulot dit je veux lui dit
lourd moi je veux la remettre à
l'endroit
comme l a fait à cros lab venu faire le
grand stade éloi le duo mauroy votre
majesté pour un ca blessés c'est vrai
lui dit laurent
pedone un sabre de bois mais pour weight
bien comme elle elle n'est qu'un loyer
eau ni vers le grand stade d'el ouali
aux mourants votre majesté mafara gelés
c'est vrai lui dit laurent tu peux
souffler sur tes droits mais pour moi ga
caubère
chasser dans la plaine donnèrent le
grand stade éloi le dit comment votre
repas bien né souffre lui
sevré lui dit le roi à lapins cours est
après mois le rwanda comme elle voulait
non parquet sur la mer le grand show des
lois le dit oh mon roi votre majesté ses
phares à noyer c'est vrai lui dit
normand
pourra crier leroy poids
et à présent le roi dagobert
ordonne à ses charmes en vassaux d'alu
ou totaux de tous tout cuit majesté on y
va mais sur le roi
[Musique]
amène au nord d'agadez
ni nicolas karr bien petite soeur
[Musique]
où
j'espère que vous avez tous chanté cette
jolie chanson avec nicolas et
pimprenelle
alors tu arrives nounours lors au
dagobert henry au trot en route cyr
bonne nuit des enfants
allez sagement vous couchez donné de
gros baiser à vos parents effet de pur
[Musique]
bonsoir patron je descends tu che mais
petit ami tu es bien pressé oui il faut
que je descende je ne les entend pas ce
n'est pas normal vas-y vite nounours
sitôt dit sitôt fait le hip hop hop hop
hop hop hop
attends je vais nettoyer mais peut être
pas maintenant tu t'attendes pape rhône
elle
donne des
noms comme ça je ne peux pas en plus non
merci minutes le jeu prend froid là
dehors c'est très bon puisque c'est
comme ça je remonte sur mon dieu
non jamais
qu'est-ce que vous fabriquez là dedans
vous avez sûrement fait des petits
[Musique]
moi je fais jamais de bêtises
je crois que tu peux à un très haut je
n'ai pas trop tout alors qu'est-ce qui
se passe
widy collant
à la salle des fêtes
avant d'aller au lit n'ose vous aimez
toilettes avant d'aller où l'humour
montre tes mains garnements
c'est du beau et là dessous
bravo à l'encrier renversé
au malin au lieu de le dire tout de
suite
[Musique]
non je ne dis pas ça arrive à tout le
monde de faire des tâches mais il faut
le dire tout de suite
on met tropez la nappe
une auto chambre haute a raison je vais
la mettre dans l'eau et demain elle sera
propre je te grande part nicolas mais va
vite te laver les mains avec beaucoup de
ce hameau
en soit
selon fo
[Musique]
ce qui l'a gentil noces louis
saïa bien scotché
ben il a produit le pays quand vous
ferez encore des bêtises vous le dire
tout de suite c'est rami promis j'irai
la chute a eu lieu
à demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nounours a tout à fait raison quand vous
faites une bêtise dit le tout de suite à
votre maman elle ne vous grondera pas on
n'y va pas trop haute bonne nuit les
enfants allez vite vous coucher du feu
de bois
[Musique]
ou le sol pas tout de suite pas trop ne
soit pas si pressée nounours et amis ma
tante jeu qu'ils vont être contents hop
hop hop hop hop hop robot soir les
enfants
vous aussi vous allez être contents car
nounours vous a réservé une surprise
au soir lui petit
chicala d'apporter la suite de
l'histoire de filippi oui je vais vous
la raconter
allons je me pose
[Musique]
ou itunes où
il fait beau allons nous promener dans
les bois de paul
les bois
propose à la maman de philippines à sa
petite fille ronde et cannes
philippines mis sur sa tête la casquette
de son papa pris un saut une pelle un
râteau un petit panier avec du pain pour
les oiseaux et suivi sa maman
avec son tambour
arrivée dans la forêt la maman s'assied
au bord du chemin sur apple philippines
sur un autre talus et se mit à émietter
sont pas pour les oiseaux
quand tout à coup elle vit dans l'herbe
tout près d'elle
il reste eh oui une fraise des bois tout
rouge puis une autre
à travers philippines en mangeant
quelques-unes puits rempli son petit
panier de toutes les phrases qu'elle
trouve à l'ena sa maman le petit panier
était plein de frère
lorsque
dibi dibi dibi le lapin blanc arrivant
au courant et mange à toutes les preuves
s'il arrive un
temps lapin attend crise et filippi mais
le lapin blanc seau va bien vite
alors philippines très en colère se mit
à taper sur son tambour de toutes ses
forces
les oiseaux se mirent à piailler très
fort et le toner trônant très fort
qui plaît philippines et sa maman
rentrèrent bien vite à la maison tout
ouïe est un moment à l'humain prophète
doigt dans la cheminée pour se sécher
attend lapin attend continuer à répéter
la petite philippine
pour lui faire oublier ce garnement de
lapin blanc
[Musique]
je ne m'en rappelle plus j'ai encore
oublié d'apporter la suite sa lente
exagère que jacques roux petit jeu vous
la porterez la prochaine fois ceux
promis et je vous laisse le lit
vous êtes content
merci ça nous fait trois livres au long
les enfants
[Musique]
admis bonne nuit les petits
la jettent un liner
fait pour
[Musique]
elle était très jolie ton histoire
nounours nicolas et pimprenelle l'on
peut couper plus léger de nouveaux
oublier la suite pas trop on y va en
route bonne nuit les enfants allez vite
vous couchez embrasse bien fort vos
parents est fait pour eux
par les enfants au que se passe-t-il
north mettront mon petit doigt vient de
me dire qu'il faut que je descende
mettre de l'ordre j'aimais le petit ami
tu crois oui on a besoin de moi en raw
le schale le mot
[Musique]
bonsoir nico
home et pimprenelle tuer le pyjama de
confrères
c'est vrai
nicolas il a pris son bac et il va
chercher ton pyjama mon pyjama tiens bon
s'annonce d'appartements pyjama
âprement
ah non non mon pyjama geoffroy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien beau meuble moi je loupe
mon pyjama pape rhône est bon
ma poutine pas preneur micmacs la
cheminée nuit oui nicolas tu peux mettre
la chemise de passeur c'est toujours une
chemise deux filles à jamais tiens ben
ali tamron mon pyjama
salon au cfi
son terrible elle vous prend toutes vos
affaires c'était coaching déchets poste
depuis juin des villes n o thomas de
l'aven ne pas habiter avec tâche earth
one ou non ce n'est pas du jab à moi
tiens ta chemise de nuit pas près d'elle
soit raisonnable c'est le pyjama de
collants alors ne pas attendre une arme
en a je n'aime pas les enfants qui se
disputent puisque c'est comme ça je m'en
vais et je ne sais pas si je reviendrai
demain
tfh panne ou bien la voilà les pyjamas
du gaston d'abord il est pas beau et
jean vais pas m a tant mieux parce que
moi je les aime bien ça suffit cette
résidence est chamayou et mais pas comme
[Musique]
excuse moi mais tu sais la fille
bon dormez-vous vite et ne vous disputez
plus jamais non plus c'est le tram et à
demain un dôme en
jette un ingénieur
pour nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
alors nounours ton petit doigt ne s'est
pas trompé il ne se trompe jamais mon
petit doigt pas trop j'ai mis de l'ordre
on y va oui en route lol lol lol dolbeau
l'aviez vu vous ne trouvez pas très
belle nounours bonne idée enfants faute
de gros
lot
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir à tous un
trou qui a team nounours pensez vous
qu'il soit trop tard pour faire du boul
mais non tu peux t'amuser avec tes amis
et faire du bruit encore un petit
instant les mamans le tir où je suis
certain qu'elle te donne la permission
aux eaux que diriez-vous les enfants tu
nous chantions tous ensemble avec du
cola elle pas pro d'elle une belle
chanson euro propre aux poteaux propos
aux
nefs nous chantons sur la route de loose
et oui c'est un la route d'el nino
vieira
louvier sur la route de louviers ya peu
en
contenu il y avait d'un côté mais quitte
à celle du cochonnet canétois
dédicace à des tas de cailloux
on a du passage des roues
[Musique]
une date a passé une belle dame va tu as
passé dans sa peau carrosse doré dans sa
peau
quant à lui
gagné de plus et qui lui pique aux
cotonniers
fiches métiers
les campagnes
les cantonniers avaient fleuri sur nos
garçons
nous cassons car si jong un si joli aux
élèves comme carrefour si je roule dans
cette affaire dont un tel que
cette réponse se fait remarquer cette
réponse je fais remarquer par sa grande
s'appliquent
[Musique]
les malheurs mois les malheurs
d'une annonce il ya beaucoup de
malheureux oui beaucoup trop comme la
campagne et oui
et des petits enfants malheureux cana
aussi oui il faut pas c'est pas bien non
heureux mais on veut pas que malheureux
je le sais mais chers petits allô oui
on ne fait pas toujours ce qu'on veut
panis ou de nuit les enfants
là j'éteins la lumière
fait de pouvoir
[Musique]
alors nounours vous avez bien chanter we
pas trop qu'est ce que tu as tu es
triste pas trop je veux que tous les
enfants soit heureux oui nounours
allons en route bonne nuit des enfants
embrasser bien fort vos parents
allez vite vous coucher une photo pour
[Musique]
e
oh
où